some people can whistle some people
whistle pretty well but most people
can't whistle like this in final night
so my international Grand Champion
whistle and I wish whistlers like myself
we we practice we practice many hours
and try to attempt to get whistling to
be taking a little bit more seriously
Lomax is one of the few people who have
devoted themselves to whistling at the
highest levels of his body his unique
sound is captured multiple international
whistling championships he's listed the
national anthem before crowds of
thousands he's appeared on television
shows including The Tonight Show Sean
Lowe Matt Johnson
[Applause]
he's even performed with circus away
whistling is taking Lomax around the
world it doesn't matter what country I'm
in if I was a little song it has way of
just writing the barriers people
appreciate it and it comes across to
people when you feel it really whistled
and it's done properly it has a way of
just reaching out and just going right
in touching
whistling might seem frivolous even
annoying to some but it's impossible to
deny it indelible place in our cultural
life we whistle to express excitement
who the CIL's a train and call our dogs
whistling is even used as a language in
places like Turkey and the Canary
Islands night course there are the
beloved popular songs with whistling
like Bobby McFerrin don't worry be happy
this is a very melodic great great piece
the bangles walk like an Egyptian of
course the whistling part I would always
whistle and the theme to The Andy
Griffith Show the whistle it backwards
and forward whistling in my sleep and my
wife said that I actually used to do
that whistle in my sleep Lomax has a
style all his own his whistling makes
even the simplest song sound
sophisticated ok for example this is how
most people would whistle pop goes the
weasel' this is but Lomax says anyone
can improve their whistling it just
takes practice practice practice
so how she beginners get started the
main thing is to realize don't purse
don't purse your lips find the location
or the spot where whistling is
comfortable for you the way I do that
only the way I would suggest you do it
is to practice in front of a mirror and
finding the circle relax relax relax
find the circle and go from there to
change pitch just change the side of the
circle lowlife likes to think of it a
little bit like the aperture of a lens
in photography in photography a smaller
aperture brings in a tighter amount of
light and gives you a more clearer
picture what it does the same thing with
whistling so the smaller the aperture
the higher the pitch larger the aperture
the lower the pitch y'all suggest
practicing alongside a piano a pitch
pipe or freak
the tuner and you should really do that
when you first start because then your
notes are gonna be tight they're gonna
be accurate and you're learning it the
right way and not just by by ear
whistling at Lomax's level also takes
proper preparation step one apply lip
balm I use cherry chapstick but anything
is good step two get a peach peaches or
nectarines give the right balance to
your mouth they clean out all the bad
stuff that's in there and you get good
liquid spit sorry so a good peach before
you start workflow is the way to go hold
on step three work out those lips it's
necessary to ensure that you keep these
muscles and the lip muscles in really
top condition and you just do this until
it begins to hurt but the real key to
pro whistling is breathing breathing is
important extremely important breathing
is everything in order for me to whistle
the song I have to first figure out how
to breathe it once I learned how to
breathe it then whistling becomes a
little bit simpler you want to be able
to
continuous continues without any blades
in fact it's breath control that lets
them conquer complex on flight of the
bumblebee when you break the knee all
air seizes and it's a matter of
controlling your breath the trumpet
planner for example is breaking the
notes and that is what you're doing with
your tongue it's very difficult and
again it takes practice making it note a
little faster each time just takes
practice in fact it took like years to
develop the techniques needed to perform
the most demanding tracks I'm combining
about three or four different whistling
styles in there when I'm going flight of
the bumblebee
I'm also humming when i whistle with
vibrato the most common style of
whistling in the one Lomax practices is
called pucker style which is exactly
what it sounds like pushing air do post
it I call it
pucker power whistling because I breathe
out the music and what pucker might be
the most common style of whistling it's
not the only there are lots of different
types of whistling there's yeah it's
very it's referring to his African
whistling this of course pepper
whistling that's what I do
there's whistling that you can do
whistling with the fingers there's palm
whistling where you used which I can't
do where you use your hands there's a
Swiss wing where you whistle between
your teeth see I can't get there
what lummix can do is his own unique
whistling sound there are a lot of good
listeners out there when I learned how
to whistle I was a young kid in church
and I would hear the Hammond b3 organ I
was trying to emulate the Hammond organ
whether it's Hammond b3 or trying to do
a roof in a guitar or something like
that
I've used the whistle to try to emulate
it listen islamics whistles amazing
grace with this organ emulation style
it's almost like two instruments are
playing at the same time what I do is I
home and use the cavity in my nose
between my nose and my upper palate to
resonate the sound the the guy in
Jurassic Park had that thing where he
blew into it and it made the funny sound
but that's kind of what I'm doing is and
it just gives it a different unique
technique is obviously critical but the
core of all Max is whistling is
emotional interpretation of songs like
his version of Mozart's Queenie the
night that's what it says this clinched
his multiple international whistling
championships you're judged on your
dexterity you judged on clarity of notes
and you're judged on the piece that you
peaked and you're judged on even your
stage presence Oh max doesn't just read
the music he researches us on what's
queen in the night if you know the Opera
the queen is telling her daughter that
she needs to go and kill this guy and
you know bring her a blood-stained
dagger by morning it's a pretty intense
song and it's emotional song so if you
can bring that team the performance it
makes for a much better performance than
just whistling it note for note in it
being right that's very good of course
but if you can bring that extra to it
also and show the emotional portions
then
explore much much better winning
performance any that dedication and
attention to detail that lends Lomax's
performances their power you have to
practice it but once you get there it's
like wow
[Music]